a lot of people talking about the Met
Gala last night I don't know if you
follow this stuff yeah one of the
biggest fashion events of the year a lot
of high-profile celebrities get dressed
up in sort of over-the-top outfits it's
a huge story in the entertainment world
cardi B wore an enormous gown you can
see right there yeah fantastic beautiful
gorgeous Jared Leto walked in carrying
his own severed head is kind of a joke
and Katy Perry was dressed as a human
chandelier well I'm excited cuz I flew
to New York yesterday for the event all
the big stars go and I had to go so I
too late you stop everyone goes and I
wanted to go so I went to the to the Met
Gala New York I have to tell you the
outfit my team put together was
absolutely ha incredible here's a photo
this is me at the Met down
yeah hold on you were not at the Met
Gala you weren't even invited Billy
widen out on that photo please okay Andy
see I flew New York to go to spar oh
that's right corner by a bar oh wait a
minute wait a minute I'm curious Andy
how did you know I wasn't at the Met
Gala because I was there
what yeah I arrived right after Katy
Perry there's video here it's a video
let's take
you know got a response was that well
yeah someone was horribly burned I I was
worried that it would hurt my career
that I would become known as the guy
that set fire to Katy Perry but
apparently no no they loved it they
loved it